welcome to the heavy spoilers show
it feels so good to be back i know i
shouldn't have left you this long but i
was waiting for this big announcement
and seeing it finally confirmed
has got me saying hallelujah there's
just been a whole host of new updates on
zack snyder's justice league dropped
online
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that you
need to know
there might be some spoilers here so if
you want to go into the film as blind as
a bat
then i highly recommend that you turn to
the dark side of the internet
aka the one division trailer i'm just
kidding
and without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so last night it was reported by
screenrun that the snyder cut was gonna
be getting an additional 70 million
dollars added to its budget
when the cut was first released you
might remember that it was
estimated to be around 20 to 30 million
dollars
but this massive price tag brings a lot
with it
now if you consider that deadpool's
entire budget was 58 million
it kind of gives you an idea of the sort
of thing that this money can be used for
not only will it be dropped on tidying
things up like darkseid
but and it's a big bat but warner
brothers are also getting back
several of the actors to shoot key
scenes for the film
now if you cast your mind back nine
months ago or 85 years in 2020 time
you might remember that zack snyder
threw a competition on his vero account
that involved winning a signed clap
aboard on this was additional texts that
said the person who won it would be
invited to watch the extra scenes being
filmed
it looks like we are indeed getting
these as it's now being confirmed that
ben affleck
gal gadot henry cavill and ray fisher
will be filming some more things for the
movie in october
the report which comes from the
hollywood reporter discusses the new
details on the project
as well as the situation with rey who
has been quite outspoken about the
studio's mistreatment of him
namely at the hands of jeff john and
joss whedon it feels like what we've
heard so far
it's just the tip of the john berg but
i'm sure more will come out in the
following months
or this could be a move by the studio to
try and buy some goodwill from him
i really don't know but we'll go through
that report in just a bit after we've
discussed what's been said by insiders
on the reshoots
now mark hughes who works as a writer
for forbes said the following
when discussing the project since it's
now public knowledge
i can say things i've not been able to
say before
the amount of dollars spent on snyder's
jl isn't a reflection of his original
cut being as
incomplete as folks used to claim it's
because new footage is being shot
beyond just finishing his cut the
original snyder cut we talked about for
the past year plus
was more than 90 complete and did not
need tens of millions to get that cut
into shape
the high dollar amount is because the
work on the film includes re-editing it
into individual episodes plus new
footage
for example there are certain dc
characters originally intended to be in
jl
but those scenes weren't filmed and it
was dropped at the time
now however those things can be added in
as well as other scenes
and it all needs different editing into
episodes with the right pacing
so now the original i'll take tens of
millions of dollars to finish snyder cut
claims
were not proven true by the budgeting
for zack snyder's justice league
the reason some press have claimed we
were right all along
is because some warner brothers folks
were falsely telling the press
no new scenes would be shot those warner
brother folks may have legitimately
thought that was true by the way
because it appears a lot of folks at the
studio are still not always sure on
what's up
partly because things are changing and
influx a lot
so a lot of folks aren't always in the
loop on everything
now lots of stuff to unpack from there
folks
and from sorry that was bad and from
that as mentioned earlier
not only will we be getting returning
cast members we'll also be getting new
characters introduced that were supposed
to be in the original cut
now there have been several reports that
martian manhunter green lantern and the
atom were all meant to be making
appearances
and that they were all part of the
storyboarding process however
due to those scenes never getting filmed
it was always up in the air
exactly what was going to happen with
them but now it looks like they're
indeed getting made
so we will see swanwick as martian man
hunter and hopefully
ryan reynolds is green linden i don't
know i don't know if i'm even joking
anymore on that last one
i think it's absolutely great that
affleck is coming back too
and as someone that didn't ever think he
would i'm so happy he's back on board
with this
and will be in the flash as well who
knows we might even get that rumored hbo
max show with him after all
but i'll of course keep you updated if
any official news on it comes out
now as for the ray fisher reports the
hollywood reporter have said the
following
warner media's investigation into
allegations of misconduct on the 2017
film
may impact how the snyder cut and spin
off the flash proceed
in october director zack snyder will
roll cameras for his extended cut of
justice league
working for warner media's hbo max
division on restoring his version of the
malign 2017 movie
that he exited because of a family
tragedy the shoot which will turn the
snyder cut into a four episode limited
series
is expected to bring back ben affleck as
batman henry cavill as superman
and gal gadot as wonder woman for new
scenes also
set to appear on the call sheet for
what's expected to be a week or so long
shoot
israeli fisher is cyborg the latter is
noteworthy because fisher is in a public
dispute with sister warner media
division warner bros
which he accuses of permitting joss
whedon the director who took
over from snyder to engage in misconduct
and abuse
while reshooting justice league fisher
also claimed that executives john berg
and jeff
johns who both have since left the
studio
enabled whedon's behavior for fisher
being cast as superhero cyborg by snyder
was supposed to be the break of a
lifetime the actor went from theater
work
and one episode of television to land
the character who was first introduced
in snyder's batman v superman dawn of
justice
then showcased more predominantly in
justice league
cyborg was also getting his own
standalone movie which was slated for
2020
but all that was years ago justice
league disappointed at the box office
and a dc film shake-up saw jeff jones
and john berg let go
to be replaced by walter hamada an
executive from warner's sister on new
line
fish's dissatisfaction came to light
june 29
when he shared a video clip of himself a
2017
san diego comic-con praising whedon but
writing on twitter he'd like to retract
every bit of that statement
on july 1st the actor elaborated calling
whedon's behavior on set gross
abusive unprofessional and completely
unacceptable
fish's remarks pushed warner media to
investigate the claims
and on august 20th he announced the
company was looking into them
that led to a back and forth between
warner media and fisher
about whether he was cooperating with
the investigation
they claimed he wasn't but he said he
was on september 4th
fischer tweeted that hamada who had no
connection to the previous warners or dc
film regime had privately disparaged
sweden and berg to him
in an effort to spare john's the studio
reported with a statement of its own
claiming fischer had not cooperated with
the investigation
and fischer fired back with a screenshot
of an email that seemed to show he had
indeed met with an investigator
he also wrote warner's has escalated
this to an entirely different level
but i'm ready to meet the challenge on
september 14th
aquaman's jason momoa reignited fish's
claims of misconduct
writing on instagram it needs to be
investigated and people need to be held
accountable
momoa's wading into the delicate issue
is said to have caught both the studio
and his own team off guard as the actor
and studio are preparing to shoot
aquaman 2
early next year insiders recall to thr
that the justice league reshoots
conducted by whedon
were messy and hastily assembled whedon
had to cram in an extensive rewrite and
reshoots
and take over post-production one person
present at the reshoots describes a set
filled with tension and says the
director was difficult with actors
but this person also says they did not
witness any physical or other abuse
jones and bergs were under pressure and
other insider notes
as they were trying to deliver a temp
poll and knew their jobs were on the
line
whedon did jettison many of fish's
scenes according to sources
and his directing style is described as
the opposite to snyder's collaborative
approach
it's also unclear if fischer filed a
complaint at the time
fischer is in talks with warner brothers
to make a cameo in the flash
a justice league spin-off movie due to
shoot next year
he has options negotiated for future
appearances
including cameos beyond the initial film
but in earlier drafts of the flash
script
cyborg was a much more active player
than the one in the current script
sources say the studio exercised its
options for flash
even upping its negotiated price for
what's described as a three scene
appearance
fish's side counted with a figure
doubling that warner brothers turned
that down
and negotiations have remained stalled
for weeks
okay so yeah sorry for just basically
reading that all out but the situation
sounds pretty crazy
and i really don't know how it's gonna
develop i kind of feel like a lot of
this might get swept under the rug
and i imagine it's very difficult for
fisher having to expose one part of a
company
whilst the other side is trying to work
with him it's super messed up
but we at the channel here stand with
ray fisher
and i really hope that he gets the
justice he deserves and i also swear
that's not a pun
now that should be you all fully caught
up and
thank you for sitting through the entire
video with me so sorry if it was a bit
ready now i'm very hyped to see what
happens
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of the latest episode
of the boys
in which we go over all the ins and outs
of it so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
also giving away a free copy of the
christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is subscribe to the
channel
drop a comment below and like the video
your mug
and when it's going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september so make
sure you get involved and best of luck
to you
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content like this early then
please consider clicking the join button
below
you can also come chat on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
you